today we have some major information
about shang-chi and the legend of the
ten rings how's it going everybody it's
worn and shang-chi is going to be the
newcomer of the MCU along with the
Eternals not too many people know too
much about shang-chi besides the fact
that he is the master of come foo but
nonetheless fans are very excited to see
him enter the MCU especially because
he's going to be bringing the Mandarin
into the MCU and I'm talking about the
real Mandarin not the fake one that we
got in Iron Man 3 and although the
Mandarin is going to be the main villain
of shang-chi and the legend of the ten
rings it's looking like shang-chi is
going to have to fight a lot more than
just the Mandarin today we have
confirmation of four new villains that
shang-chi is going to have to go up
against in shang-chi and the legend of
the ten rings so I'm going to go over
each villain in this video I'm also
still doing my Xbox one or ps4 giveaway
to enter all you have to do is be
subscribed to my channel leave a like on
the video and a comment down below so
thanks to casting information that has
been released about shang-chi we now
know of four new villains that are going
to be entering the movie and these four
villains are steel cloth moving shadow
razor fist and a ghost maker now steel
claw does not exist in the comics there
is no character by the name of steel
claw that exists unless and this is what
many people suspect is that steel claw
is actually going to be tiger claw now
tiger claw is a character from the
comics in the comics tiger claw went to
foo Manchu and demanded that he be a
syphon Lodge Master tiger claw ends up
killing three siphon masters and Foom on
shoot grants him at the position years
later he would go on to challenge Cheng
Chi and would end up being defeated by
Sheng G so although this casting
information says steel claw they could
be referring to Tiger Claw the other
three villains moving shadow razor fist
and ghost maker are from the comics
moving shadow in the comics is actually
the half-brother of shang-chi and the
comics shengqi's father is foo meant you
and foo Mon shoe is evil and shang-chi
technically failed his father by
deciding not to be evil so foo Manchu
had another son who replaced shang-chi
and that son was moving shadow moving
shadow embraced his father's teachings
and trainings and he was then ordered to
kill his half brother Sheng Chi moving
shadow gladly accepted the task although
he was defeated by shang-chi hao
ever shang-chi would not kill him and
when he would not kill him in battle his
father foo Manchu ended up killing
moving shadow sounds like a really good
debt the next is razor fist and there
are actually three different versions of
razor fist and the comics two of which
are brothers razor fist actually doesn't
have any fists instead he has two blades
that are attached to the ends of his
arms and of like the other shang-chi
villains he of course was defeated by
shang-chi in the comics and the last one
is ghost maker but ghost makers real
name is a Grigory Savchenko he was born
in the Soviet Union and his father was a
high-ranking KGB member who trained him
through martial arts for 15 years his
training was complete when he killed the
top ten Western spies while attacking a
military camp he fought and was defeated
by shang-chi however ghost maker has
come back to life on several different
occasions so there is a possibility that
he could be defeated and then be brought
back to life in shang-chi and The Legend
of the Tim rings so there certainly are
going to be a lot of villains in this
movie however it is rumored at this
point in time that there is going to be
some sort of underground Fight Club
tournament that happens that shang-chi
is going to be a part of so if this ends
up being true this is most likely where
shang-chi is going to fight all of these
villains so let me know what you think
about these new villains being added to
shang-chi and the legend of the ten
rings and to let me know what you're
most excited about for the movie be sure
to comment down below and like the video
and subscribe to my channel so you can
have a chance to win an Xbox one or a
ps4 and so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof